ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกๆคน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนถ้าเป็นไงคะผู้เรียมวัน
นี้สวย
ขอบคุณค่ะวันนี้อยู่ที่บ้าน
วันนี้อ้อกล่องชาร์จนะคะปากชัดหน้า
สวย 5 โอเคค่ะก่อนอื่นวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะวันนี้วันอะไรนะวัน
จันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 14 ค่ะวัน
ที่ 14 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมีนาคมเดือน
มีนาคมปีพตตเท่าไหร่คะขอ 2 คัน 560
555 พ.ศ 2565 ปีคศเท่าไหร่คะ
ข้อ
2022 ค่ะ 2022 นะคะคู่เรียมวันนี้
ครูเอ๋
อยากมีคำถาม
มีคำถามว่าว่าครูเรียนเนี่ยชอบดูหนังไหม
ดูใช่ไหมดูหนังหนังแม่นักเรียนก็เป็นหนัง
ฮอลลีวู๊ดหนังบริเวณวูดหนังอะไรของฮ่องกง
มีอะไรอ่ะหนังจีนบริเวณก็อินเดียที่
อเมริกาก็คอลีวูดหนังฮอลลีวู๊ดที่ประเทศ
ไทยก็หนังไทยนะคะแต่ว่าถ้าอยู่ในทีวีน่ะ
เป็นละคร
นะเราพูดว่าระครให้อยู่ในทีวีถ้าอยู่อ่ะ
ในโรงหนังคือเราต้องเดินไปนอกบ้านแล้วก็
ไปซื้อตั๋วนะคะก็เป็นผิวหนังก็ไปดูคู๋จะ
เป็นคนชอบดูหนังชอบดูละครตอนนี้ไม่ได้ดู
ไม่ได้ดูหนังเพราะว่ามีโคเวทก็เลยไม่ไปดู
หนังแบบครูเอ๋น่ะดูเน็ตฟลิกซ์
ตอนนี้ดูเน็ตฟลิกซ์ดูตากูเองจะเป็นหมี
แพนด้าอยู่ล่ะ
ชอบดูหนังฮอลลีวู๊ดหนังไทยหนังบริสุทธิ์
ชอบดูทั้งหมดนะคะอ่ะหนังคุยชอบดูหนังจีน
หนังคนจีน
ทางทิศแต่ว่าใช้ใช่ไหมคะมันจีนพูดภาษาไทย
ไปหนังจีนสวยๆนะคะต้องผู้หญิงสวยๆบินได้
ผู้หญิงบินได้ค่ะทำไมต้องอ่ะโอเคผู้หญิง
จะบินบินบินได้แบบนี้ก็ไม่ได้เล่นบินเค้า
เนี่ยคอก็เหมือน Superman  Superman ก็พอ
ได้ใช่ไหมคะอ่ะงั้นหนังจีนจะมีผู้หญิงสวย
ๆแล้วก็
รอยเหาะไปอ่ะกูอีกแล้วชอบแบบนั้นแตกวัน
นี้ครูเอ๋อยากจะรู้ว่าคุณเรียมเนี่ยดูชอบ
ดูหนังใหม่
เรียมไม่ชอบดูหนังนะแบบดูดูน้อยมาก
ดูแลหน่อยใช่ครูเฒ่าเกิดครูเอ๋บอกบอก
เรียนมาว่านางเรื่องนี้ดีเตรียมก็จะโอเค
ไปดู
ตัวที่บอกเมียมากหนังเรื่องนี้ดีเตรียมก็
โอเคไปดูแต่ไม่ใช่แบบเห็นใน YouTube เห็น
ใน Facebook แล้วก็จะไปดูไม่มีแล้วที่ไป
ดูหนังมามีเรื่องไหนที่คุณเรียมชอบมากๆ
ไหมคนค่ะโคเรียมถามกูอากูเอมีเยอะมีเยอะ
นะที่ชอบนะมีเยอะมากไม่มีอยู่เรื่องนึง
ตัวเองชอบมากแต่ว่าวันนี้ครูเอ๋จะไม่เล่า
แต่ท้ายครัวลืมเรา
จะ
ก็บอกชื่อเรื่องได้นะคะ DM จะได้ไปดูก็
อยากรู้จักครูเรียมก่อนว่าครูเรียมน่ะชอบ
หนังเรื่องอะไร
เตรียม
ชอบหนังเรื่อง
ลาลาแลนด์
ลาลาแลนด์หนังไทยหนัง
คะลีวูดหนังบริเวณหนังจีนหนังเกาหลีหนัง
อะไรคะกูเองไม่เคย
หนังฮอลี Hollywood หรือเปล่าไม่ใช่หนัง
จีนไม่ใช่หนังไทย
คนเล่นเป็นฝรั่ง
ใช่ค่ะเป็นฝรั่งจมูกโด่งนะเป็นฝรั่งนะเออ
นี่ใครเล่นน่ะพระเอกรู้จักไหมพระเอกเลียม
ก็ไม่รู้จักนางเอกก็ไม่รู้จักหื้อ
ไปหาให้ดูกูลืมไม่ไม่เป็นไรเดี๋ยวกูไปหา
ให้ไหม
อ่ะคุยกับก็ได้ทั้ง iPad ใหญ่กว่าอ๋อ
เพราะว่าเรียนดูภาพไงกูเองเดิมดูภาพ
ดูวีดีโอ
ไหนคะร้านครูเอ๋ไม่เคยไม่เคยดู
ลาลาแลนด์
ตารางๆอ๋อ City  Of  Stars
ลาลาแลนด์ใครเล่นน่ะ
เดี๋ยวหาก่อนตัวเองน่าจะรู้จักก็ได้คนนี้
คนนี้ก็ไม่น่าคือครูเอ๋ชอบดูหนังแต่ไม่
รู้ชื่อดาราแอคุณหมอ
ผู้ชายรู้แต่ครูเองไม่ค่อยชอบดูคนนี้ผู้
หญิงไม่รู้จักอ่า
ผู้ชายรู้จักครูเอ็มกูเองไม่ค่อยชอบดารา
คนนี้คือไม่ใช่ไม่ชอบเฉยๆเฉยๆครูเอกก็เลย
ไม่ดูแบบถ้าเป็นอะไรนะบีโอโด้ ryona เด้อ
เอื้อย
ลีโอ
ชื่ออะไรนะเดี๋ยวก็ลืมไปด้วย
อีโอ
เอชอบด้วยค่ะโอ้
ชอบวิลสมิธ
ชอบใครนะ
ชอบวิลสมิธชอบอ่ะ
The ค่ะพี่โอ้ชอบชอบทิปส์เล็กคุณป้า
ทิพย์ผมเป็นนัตสึกันเล่นกีตาร์
คนนั้นคิดกูเอกก็จำชื่อดาราไม่ค่อยได้จำ
ได้แต่ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงก็จะชอบผู้ชายจะจำ
ไม่ค่อยได้หน้านี้ลาลาแลนด์อ่ะครูเอ๋ไม่
เคยดูนักเรียนเคยดูไหม
ไม่รู้คู่เรียมเล่าให้ครูฟังได้ไหมคะ
ลาลาแลนด์ได้เรื่องเป็นยังไง
ทำไมคุยเหลี่ยมช่าง
มืดเรียนชอบดูภาพดูวีดีโอเพราะว่าหนัง
เรื่องนี้เขาได้รับรางวัลเกี่ยวกับคาบสวย
วีดีโอสวย
เต็มก็เลยดู
ได้รับรางวัลคือ
ออสการ์เหรอคะรางวัลออสการ์น่ะ
หูสต้าไหมหรอไม่แน่ใจนะเพราะว่าช่วงเวลา
มีหนังก็จะต้องไปที่ออสการ์แล้วชิงรางวัล
ให้นะเล่มได้นะคิดว่าได้ลาลาแลนด์ได้รับ
รางวัลเยอะมากเกี่ยวกับเรื่อง
นี่
ดาราแลนด์ได้รับรางวัลนักแสดงผู้หญิงยอด
เยี่ยม
นักแสดงนักแสดงก็คือผู้หญิงอย่างเช่นอะไร
นะใครนะก็มีการแข่งกันใช่ไหมอาหารนักแสดง
ผู้หญิงคุ่ก็รู้จักแอนเจลิน่าโจลี่นะคะก็
ชอบโจลีนักแสดงผู้หญิงที่ได้รับรางวัลก็
คือ Emma สโตขอเชิญมากผู้หญิงที่ n มาก
เพราะแสดงเก่งล่ะคะ
ใช่ค่ะเป็นแสดงเก่งมาก
หรูได้รับรางวัลมีเยอะมากกูเอ๋มันจะให้ดู
อันนี้คือรางวัลที่เขาได้
อ่านไม่เห็น
[เพลง]
แม่หนึ่งหญิงยอดเยี่ยมยอดเยี่ยมก็ขึ้น
เก่งที่สุดอ่ะช้าคนถ่ายวีดีโอถ่ายวีดีโอ
ชายภาพถ่ายภาพยอดเยี่ยมถ่ายวีดีโอสวยใช่
มั้ยก็ยอดเยี่ยมยอดเยี่ยมขึ้นเก่งที่สุด
เพลง
ใช่เพลงหรือว่าดนตรีประกอบ
เพลงกับดนตรีต่างกันยังไงคะ
ถ้าเกิดถ้าเกิดเพลงประกอบก็จะมีคนร้องได้
ใช่ไหมคะถ้าเกิดดนตรีก็แบบไวโอลิงแต่ไม่
มีคนร้องไม่มีหรอก
ไม่มีนักร้องนะคะคะนักร้องถ้าพูดถึงนัก
ร้องครูเรียมชอบนักร้องคนไหนอ่ะคู๋ชอบนัก
Whitney  Houston
โหนานมาก
ไปแล้วก็คุยชอบนี้กูสั้นนะคะชอบมากงั้นก็
with นี้ก็จะร้องเพลงเนาะร้องเพลงร้อง
เพลงเวลาร้องเพลงก็มีดนตรีก็คือจะมี
กีตาร์มีเปลี่ยนโอมีอิเลคโทรนิคลองโปร่งๆ
ขึ้นไปรู้เสียงอะไรก็มีกลองตีกลองนะคะแต่
ว่าถ้าที่ครูเรียนบอกว่าดนตรีประกอบยอด
เยี่ยมก็เป็นแค่เปลี่ยน o  r  r กิตตา
Guitar  Bass ตามไม่มีนักร้องไม่มีราคาย
เราก็สั่งเรื่องลาลาแลนด์นะคะเขาเป็นแบบ
ก็เหมือน musical ค่ะพี่เอ๋มีเป็นละคร
เพียงๆ
เป็นแบบพูดพูดพูดแล้วก็ร้องเพลงพูดพูด
แล้วก็ร้องเพลง
ให้
ชอบมาก
ในเรื่อง
เรื่องเรื่องมันเป็นยังไงพี่คนเดียว
บอกชอบเนี่ย
ในเรื่องผู้หญิงเขาอยากเป็นนักแสดงละคร
เวที
เวทีครูเรียนวาดเวทีได้ไหมคะ
เวทีก็จะมีคนดูนะคะ
คนยืนดูเหรอนั่งดูคะนั่งมาหาคนนั่งดู
คนนั่งดู
นั่งดูเยอะๆค่ะแต่
ผู้หญิงก็ก็อยากเป็น
นักแสดง
ละครเวที
คูเรียมอยากเป็นไหมไม่ค่ะ
อยากไป
ก่อน
ชอบๆชอบดูได้อย่าง Action
จะคุยเคยแบบนี้
อะไรนะเนื้อหาลืมไม่เคยดูละครเวทีมีที่
โรงเรียนเออครูเอกเคยเล่นละครเวที
คู๋อยู่ที่เวทีแต่ว่าเป็นละครไทยนะคะตอน
ตอนตอนอยู่โรงเรียนตอนเป็นครูก็เล่นละคร
เวทีเป็นคนแก่เขาหวานนี้
ฝันว่า
ถ้าทั้งหมดเป็นหัวใหญ่มีอะไรนะ
แล้วถ้าครูเหตุจะเล่นละครเวทีครูอยากไป
เล่นเป็นอะไรคะเป็นคนบ้าค่ะ
อ้าวทำไมคะทำไมถึงอยากเป็นคุณมาก
ไม่รู้จะชอบอ่ะรู้สึกว่าถ้าเราเล่นเป็นคน
บ้าเลยคน
ไอ้คิวมันมีมีละครที่ที่ที่มีเด็กคนนึง
อ่ะที่
แขนขาไม่โอเคขาขาเนี่ยไม่ดีแล้วก็อ่ะ
เออพี่กานต์แล้วก็ไม่ค่อยได้เรียนหนังสือ
เนี่ยคุยชอบแล้วครูเอกก็อยากจะเป็นคนบ้า
เพราะคุยรู้สึกว่าเวลา
เวลาแบบอยากรู้ว่าเราแสดงเป็นคนบ้าจะเป็น
ยังไงคือเคยดูเราดูทีวีแล้วก็มีเรื่องที่
อยากมีคนบ้าแล้วดาราสวยๆต่อไปเป็นคนบ้า
เนี่ยโอ๊ยมันยาก
ก็เลยอยากเป็นคนบ้าอยากเล่นแล้วเป็นคนบ้า
จะได้เป็นคนแก่
แอบ
อยากจะ
คนบ้ามันก็จะมีบ้านหลายๆแบบไหนก็ได้
เอาไว้ครั้งถัดไปดีกว่าเดี๋ยวก็
อยากฟังลาลาแลนด์ครูเอกก็อยากปัง
นางเอกเขาก็เลยไป
ออดิชั่นหลายๆครั้งค่ะ Audition ครั้งที่
1  Audition ครั้งที่ 2  Audition ครั้ง
ที่ 3 ก็ก็
พูดออดิชั่นใช่ไหมเห้ยพูดออดิชั่นเหมือน
กัน
ประกวดไปแต่ก็ไม่ชั่นนะไม่ใช่ความปวดให้
ไม่ใช่เขารีบไปแคช Audition คนไทยใช้ครับ
ศัพท์ไปเลยนะคะนักเรียนไปออดิชั่นนะคะก็
คือไปแล้วก็มีสระมีมีมีมีบทเราได้บทแล้ว
ก็อ่านอ่านแล้วก็ไปแสดงให้กับครีมที่
เลือกนักแสดงเนี่ยดูใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะก็ไป
ออดิชั่นเราก็
ได้งานบ้างไม่ได้งานบ้าง
เราก็นางเอกก็อย่าเป็นคนที่แบบ
มีคนรู้จักเยอะๆอยากมีชื่อเสียงว่างั้นมี
ชื่อเสียงใช่แต่ว่าตอนนี้เมื่อเราสองคน
ใช่ไหม
เรามีชื่อเสียงอยู่ใช่ไหมค่ะนิดเดียวนะ
ถ้าเราต้องเช็ค Subscribe เท่าไหร่กดไลค์
เท่าไหร่นักเรียนคะกดไลค์ให้ครูเยอะๆนะคะ
ถ้ากดไลค์กด Subscribe เยอะๆก็แสดงว่ามี
ชื่อเสียงมีคนคนๆรู้จัก
ตัวเองเหรอครูเรียม
รู้จักเยอะๆค่ะก็คือนิดเสียงชายแล้วเขาก็
ไปเจอกับพระเอกพระเอกที่เป็นผู้ชาย
มีผู้หญิงเป็นนางเอกผู้หญิงเป็นนางเอกก็
ต้องมีพระเอกผู้ชายไม่มีพระเอกก็
เป็นน้ำเปลี่ยนโอ
เป็นจะวาดเหมือนไหน
กินโล
เล่น
ไม่เป็นอ่ะและ
แล้วเขาก็เล่นเปียโนได้เก่งมากนะคะค่ะเขา
ก็อยากมีชื่อเสียงเหมือนกัน
พระเอกเป็นนักเป็นหน่อเล่นเก่งแต่ว่าได้
เล่นในเวทีละครหรือยังคะ
ไม่ค่ะเล่นในร้านอาหารปค่ะเล่นในร้าน
อาหารก็จะมีโต๊ะ
มีเก้าอี้
แล้วก็มีคนเข้าไปกินอาหารเรา
เจอกันยังไงนางเอกไปหา
พระเอกที่ร้านอาหารหรือนางเอกไปแล้วกิน
อาหารที่ร้านอาหารแล้วเจอกัน
เล่นคิดว่านางเอกนางเอกไปกินอาหารในร้าน
อาหารเข้าเตรียมจำได้จำได้ว่านางเอกไปกิน
อาหารที่ร้านอาหารมีพระเอกก็เล่นเปียโน
พระเอกร้องเพลงไหม
ไม่
ว่าในเรื่องนี้มันเป็นละครเพลงค่ะผู้ชาย
กับผู้หญิงก็ร้องเพลงไปด้วย
ทั้งเรื่อง
ไปฟังเพลงว่างั้น
ที่มันอ๋อกูเอกเคยฟังเพลงไหมเพลงของหนัง
เรื่องนี้ที่แบบร้องอีกทีเดียว
คือครูเอ๋อ่ะเคยดูเคยดูดูหนังที่เหมือน
ครูเหลี่ยมบอกอ้ะที่หนังที่พูดแล้วก็ร้อง
เพลงพูดแล้วก็ร้องเพลงเออ
ก็ก็ก็ถามว่าชอบไหมเวลาดูก็ชอบนะแต่ว่า
เวลาที่เห็นหนังอันนี้มาอ้อหนังแล้วก็
ร้องเพลงคู่เอกก็ไม่ได้คิดจะดูแต่เคยไปดู
เนี่ย 1 เรื่องอีกหนึ่งเรื่องกันที่
เพื่อนชวนก็ไปดูพูดร้องเพลงก็ดีนะดีบ่คิด
แม่นเล่นมั้งก็ดีแต่ถามว่าเวลาเห็นอย่าง
เงี้ยเออ
จะนึกภาพไม่ค่อยออกนะก็ไม่ค่อยได้ชอบหนัง
ที่
พูดแล้วก็ร้องเพลงแต่ถ้าไปดูไปดูละครเวที
เลยก็คือดูเข็นคนแล้วก็มีแสดงมันเหมือนๆ
ไปดูโอเปร่า Opera ก็เหมือนละครเวทีถ้า
แบบแม่กูเองก็จะไปดูถ้าอย่างนี้ชอบ
ก็เลยนึกภาพที่คูเรียมเบาะไม่ออกอะไร
ลาลาแลนด์
ไปดูเรื่อง
พระเอกกับนางเอกก็หลักการอ๋อสองคนต่างกัน
Happy  Ending ใช่ไหมคะ
ไม่ใช่
คนรักมีแต่ว่าพระเอกก็มีความฝันของพระเอก
ว่านางเอกก็มีความฝันของนางเอกความฝันคำ
ขวัญคือ
นางเอกนางเอกก็อยากเป็น
อยากเป็นอะไรเป็นนักแสดงละครเวที
ใหญ่แสดงที่เวทีอันนี้เป็นความฝันของนาง
เอกแล้วพระเอกนะคะมีความฝันว่าอะไรให้ก็
อยากเป็นนักเป็น No
[เพลง]
ถ้าอย่างนั้นก็พระเอกเล่นเป็น No  No  No
นางเอกแสดง
ใช่ไหมไม่ใช่ค่ะนางเอกก็จะไปออดิชั่นไป
ออดิชั่นแล้วก็แสดงบนเวทีค่ะแสดงบนเวที
แล้วพระเอกพระเอกก็ยังไม่มีเวลาไปดูหมอ
เสียใจไหมอ่ะ
เสียใจนางเอกเสียใจไอเสียดายไม่ก็เสียใจ
แต่พระเอกก็อยากเป็นเป็นโมงแล้วก็ไปเล่น
เปลี่ยนหนูค่ะนางเอกก็อยากเป็นนักแสดงก็
ไปแสดงละครในทีแล้วไม่มีปลา
อ้าวไม่มีเวลามาเจอกัน
เกิดอะไรขึ้นเขาก็เลยเลิกกัน
ไปเขาไม่มาทำงานด้วยกัน
นักแสดงก็ต้องมีนักแสดงก็ต้องมีเป็นโน
เล่นด้วยนิใช่ไหม
เขาเลิกกันค่ะพี่เอง
แล้วในตอนสุดท้ายอ่ะยังเสียใจมากเพราะว่า
เพราะอะไรก็มีร้านอาหารของตัวเองดูเอก
มีร้านอาหารสำหรับเล่นเปียโนได้ทุกวัน
มีร้านอาหารของตัวเองค่ะแล้วก็มีคนคนนะคะ
มาฟังคนมาเยอะๆไม่อยู่ตรงหน้าเหลี่ยมเลย
อ่ะ
มีคนเยอะมากๆค่ะมากๆค่ะมาฟังพระเอกเล่น
เปียโนค่ะ
ไอ้เอกก็เล่นเปียโน
เก่งใช่ไหม
มากคนเยอะมากๆมาฝากละอีกแล้วนางเอกก็มา
นางเอกก็เป็น
ผู้หญิงที่มีชื่อเสียงมากๆแสดงว่านางเอก
ไปไปพจน์สอบบทละครเนี่ยไอ้ออดิชั่นทดสอบ
ดูละครเอ่อทดสอบบทละครบ่อยๆจนชนะ
ค่ะใช่แล้วก็เป็นนักแสดงละครเวทีที่เวที
จนชนะแล้ว
นี้ชนะโว่ทุกคนดูแล้วบอกเก่งใช่ไหมคะ
ความฝันความฝันที่อยากจะเป็นนักแสดง
สำเร็จใช่ไหมคะสำเร็จ
สำเร็จ
แล้วก็มาที่ร้านอาหาร
ใช่เกิดอะไรสองคนเจอกันอีกเลิกกันไปแล้ว
ใช่ไหมเลิกแล้วก็ไม่ทันใดกันแล้วก็ไม่เจอ
กันอีกแต่ว่านางเอกก็
มากินอาหารกับไก่ผู้ชายอีกคนอื่น
นี่
ผู้ชาย
ผู้ชายค่ะอันนี้นางเอกผู้หญิงค่ะ
ใช่มีแฟนเหรอมี
แฟนค่ะมีแฟนกัน
เราพระเอกอ่ะเห็นไหม
เห็นค่ะพระเอกก็เห็นพระเอกนางเอง
ไม่มีค่ะเอกยังไม่มีแฟนใหม่ยังไม่มีแฟน
ใหม่นางเอกมีแฟนใหม่ใช่หนึ่งจำได้ว่านาง
เอกมีรูปด้วยนะหรอ
ลูกแล้วแต่ว่าลูกไม่ได้มากินข้าวลูกอยู่
ที่บ้าน
แล้วพระเอกเห็นแล้วพระเอกทำยังไงอ่ะก็เขา
ยังยังรักนางเอกไหมคะใช่เรื่องคิดว่านาง
เอกก็รักพระเอกก็รัก
สองคนยังรักกันใช่ค่ะแล้วก็คิดคิดถึง
เมื่อก่อนอ่ะ
ก็คิดถึงเมื่อก่อนว่าเราอยากเป็นนักเป็น
นอนค่ะผู้หญิงยาเป็นนักแสดงสวยๆค่ะ
แต่ว่าเราไม่ได้อยู่ด้วยกันเงินเราแยกออก
จากกันแล้วก็ไปทำงานไปทำงานค่ะกลับมาเจอ
กันอีกทีผู้ชายก็เรื่องดวงโนได้เก่งมาก
ผู้หญิงก็
แสดงได้เก่งมากแต่รักกันไม่ได้
ก็ว่าผู้หญิงมีแฟนแล้ว
อุ้ยเศร้าจังพระเอกน่าสงสารอ้า
ที่ให้ทำยังไงดีเข้าไปเอกน่าสงสารแต่งนี้
แต่งยังโสด
เรียนยังโสดกูเองไม่ได้ป่ะ
เดี๋ยวเราเชื่อพระเอกตัวเองแต่งงานแล้ว
เห็นช่วยพระเอกไม่ได้ไม่มาผมชื่อคือ
สำหรับครูเอ๋ครูเอกรู้สึกว่า
เป็นคนคิดน้องถ้าสองคนรักกันจริงๆมันต้อง
หรอก
ต้องรอรอกันจริงๆไม่ใช่ว่าเอ๊ยไม่มีเวลา
ไม่มีเวลาแล้วเลิกกันอันเนี้ยกูเองไม่
ค่อยเข้าใจอ่ะเพราะว่าเพราะว่าผู้เห็น
แล้วเนี่ยคุยจะเศร้าจะรู้สึกเสียดสมัยอ่ะ
ทำไมเพราะว่าครูเอ๋กับสาวเมียเวลาเป็นแฟน
กันสามีก็อยู่ต่างประเทศ
ร้านอยู่ต่างประเทศประมาณ
8  7 ปี 8 ปีเอาอยู่ที่ประเทศอะไรนะคะ
ที่อยู่ที่ญี่ปุ่น
ไม่ได้อยู่ที่ประเทศไทยก็โทรศัพท์ 1 วัน 1
ครั้งโทรศัพท์คุยกัน
อ๋อคือขึ้นคุยกันนาน 8 ปีพพอดีอยากจะ
ประมาณประมาณก็คือสามีจะอยู่เมืองไทยและ
เป็นแฟนกันประมาทอยู่เมืองไทยเจอกันและก็
2 ปีละ 7 ปี 7 ปีที่ไม่เจอกัน
เจอกันเจอกัน 1 ปี 1  1 ปีประมาณ 1 ครั้ง
1ปี1ครั้งสามีจะบินบินมาประเทศไทยสุรมี
เครื่องบินแล้วก็มาประเทศไทยครูเอ๋น่ะก็
อยู่ประเทศไทยเป็นครูสามีก็ทำงานที่
ญี่ปุ่นก็
ก็สองคนก็เออ
จะเรียกว่าหล่อไหมรู้สึกไว้ใจกันน่ะก็คือ
ไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรคือไม่เลิกกันชนะไม่
เลิกกันไม่ได้รู้สึกว่าเมื่อไหร่จะมา
เมื่อไหร่จะมาไม่ได้รู้สึกแบบนั้นเพราะ
ว่าถ้าทำตามร้านและก็ทำแล้วก็โทรศัพท์คุย
กัน 1 วันละ 1 ครั้งประมาณครึ่งชั่วโมง
ก็คุยทุกวันครึ่งชั่วโมงถึงหนึ่งชั่วโมง
คุยคุยแพงไหมคุย
ยังไม่รู้ไม่รู้ด้วยนะว่าถ้าเกิดเรียนจะ
คุยคุยกับใครครึ่งชั่วโมงหนึ่งชั่วโมง
เรียบดึกพูดว่าอะไรฉันจะเออ
พูดอะไรเป็นแฟนเป็นแฟนเป็นแฟนแล้วก็จะมี
topic หรอกินข้าวหรือยังแล้วไหมอ่าวัน
นี้โอเคมั้ยไม่สบายหรือเปล่า
อย่าลืมดื่มน้ำนะไม่มีอะไรหรอก
ตัวเองก็เลยไม่เข้าใจเวลาที่แบบเอ้ยคนนี้
ทำงานแค่นี้ทำงานไม่มีเวลาแล้วก็เหมือน
กัน
ไม่ฟังแล้วมันรู้สึกเสียใจอ่ะใช่ยังไงดึง
ก็คิดเหมือนกันเสียใจใช่ไหมลาลาแลนด์สอง
คนทำงานไม่เหมือนกันแล้วก็ต้องเลิกกัน
เถาะโอ๊ยทำไมอ่ะ
แล้วก็สุดท้ายที่ผู้ชายก็ทำงานดีผู้หญิง
ก็ทำงานดีแต่รักกันไม่ได้เรียงเสียใจมาก
ไม่มี Happy  Ending ใช่มั้ยเนี่ย
ไม่ปิดเดี๋ยวก็อยากให้ Happy  Ending นะ
ไม่ดูค่ะครูเรียม
ตอนแรกอ่ะเตรียมคิดว่าผู้หญิงเดินๆไป
เที่ยวผู้หญิงเดินเดินเข้ามาในร้านอาหาร
ค่ะแล้วผู้หญิงกับผู้ชายจะกลับมารักกัน
เลี้ยงคิดว่านะแต่ว่าก็มีผู้ชายคนหนึ่ง
เดินๆเข้ามาก็คือแต่งงานแล้ว
เสียใจมากกูเองไม่ต้องดูก็ได้ไม่ดูค่ะเออ
ไม่ดูอันนี้ไม่ดูคุยทราบดูแบบมีความสุข
งั้นคู่เอกชอบชอบเรื่องก็มีเวลาไหมเนี่ย
กูเห็นชอบดู
เอกชอบเรื่องอะไรใช่ไหมกูแอบชอบเรื่อง
อะไรเก๋บอกชื่อเอาไว้นะคะนักเรียนให้นัก
เรียนไปดูอูเอชอบเรื่อง The  fifth
Element
mn
ชอบมากคู๋ดู 5 ครั้ง
5 ครั้งแล้วครูเอ๋เอ๋ก็
บอกทุกคนแล้วก็ดูอีกดูอีกดูอีกจริงถ้ามัน
ดูไปเสร็จครั้งแล้วค่ะดูสิทธิ์ครั้งกูเอก
ก็ยังชอบแบบชอบมาแต่ว่าแล้วเอาไว้ค่ะทุก
คนน่ะฟังคู๋แล้วไปดูไม่มีใครชอบเลยอ้าว
ไม่มีใครชอบเลยแต่กูเองชอบหน้าเรียวกำลัง
จะบอกให้กูอีกเล่าให้เฮียฟังเรียนจะได้ไป
ดูไอ้คูณเรียนต้องมาฟังเอกก่อนอาทิตย์
หน้านะๆในคลิปหน้าหน้าดีกว่าฟิตหน้าดี
กว่าโอเคมีกันอีกคิดมากสำหรับคลิปนี้ต้อง
ลาไปก่อนค่ะผู้เตรียม
เลยนะบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ